tu te dis que ça peut pas empirer eh ben
si ça va empirer ça va encore crevé ça
va encore tué il ya l'entendre ça j'ai
promis à mon équipage de les ramener en
un seul morceau
je voyais déjà morts où est le reste de
la troisième section
elle est devant toi sergent collyre je
suis votre nouveau copilote l'école de
blindés
ça c'est chez nous je sais même pas à
quoi ressemble l'intérieur d'un char lui
perd rien pour attendre
commencée en tuant des allemands en
afrique lâche tu des allemands en
allemagne puis avec ces messieurs depuis
des années
si vous laissez passer ses troupes on
est dans les choux on ne peut compter
que sur vous
je n'ai déjà fait moi même
transmission prête gordo occasionnera
dit ok normal hockey bible envoyait aux
élèves geslin prochain
tantôt
les idéaux sont pacifiques
l'histoire est violente
attends de voir de voir quoi ce qu'un
homme peut faire un autre homme
j'ai peur aussi ça va s'arrêter bientôt
mais avant ça il ya un tas de gens qui
doivent encore mourir pour soi quand
même un dollar 35 par jour n'a jamais eu
meilleur boulot jamais une meilleur
boulot je mets une meilleur boulot
il arrive combien ils sont ils sont 300
ça nous met à 5 contre 3 sans s'est
jamais débiner sait pas aujourd'hui
comment s'y mettre on peut encore se
battre caen se battre
oui